[Music]
what should a country do if another
country ceases one of its citizens in
what looks like hostage diplomacy
sadly this is not a hypothetical
question iran holds several western
citizens on flimsy charges
more about qadhafi sees two swiss
businessmen after swiss authorities
arrested her son for battery
and just recently china effectively
admitted to engaging in similar hostage
diplomacy which is a form of gray zone
warfare
one strategy is to do like switzerland
did and suspend all the visas issued to
the offending country
a more effective alternative would be
for the targeted country to suspend the
visas of selected members of the
perpetrator countries elite including
their families
remember the children of the elites
often live in the west
another strategy would be a luxury goods
embargo
suspend exports of designer brand
clothes shoes bags and jewelry it too
would primarily hit the elite
yes designer clothes have nothing to do
with hostage diplomacy but in the gray
zone the key is to respond with
surprising moves
some of the ideas presented in this
video are from my new book the
defender's dilemma to learn more check
the links provided
also let us know what other topics you'd
like our scholars to cover in 60 seconds
and be sure to like and subscribe for
more research and videos from aei